[Music]
hey you guys I'm back again said I would
do a book review today about some
Christmas stuff because I need to do
some Christmas horror over this week I
kind of got behind uh so yeah but before
we start talking about that let me just
mention uh today's affiliate who is
audible obviously most of you guys know
what audible is uh it's a very large uh
repository owned by Amazon that has tons
and tons of audiobooks and podcasts and
Anything Audio related that you might
want to listen to and if you click on
the link down in my description box you
will get a free 30-day trial of audible
which uh which means that you can listen
to anything that is available on their
platform for absolutely free and also
you will get um one credit that you can
use to purchase something that you can
keep forever if you're already an Amazon
Prime member then you actually get two
credits that you can use again um on
something that you can keep forever so
yeah audible is a really cool service I
uh my own books my own audiobooks are on
it as well so you could absolutely go on
there and listen to those if you wanted
to do that so yeah click the link down
in the description box I do get a small
commission if you go on there and sign
up for the deal and everything like that
but it's a great service I use it myself
and all you got to do is click on the
link so yeah uh Christmas and if you
will note I'm actually wearing kind of a
sweater today because it's kind of cold
not well not cold but it's like Florida
cold you know what I mean it's like
55° which for Florida I mean it's better
than 95 degrees like it usually is so I
mean I'll take it so I'm just like well
I'm going to get like all seasonal all
up in here and have like a sweater on
even though this is not a seasonal
sweater at all it just has like a like a
death tarot card on it so there you go
but yeah so obviously it's a week before
Christmas uh you know Christmas was
approaching fast as it does every year
the faster the older you get honestly
and it just kind of occurred to me that
other than a wait further instructions
which I reviewed last week I think I had
and I didn't even realize that that was
a Christmas horror until after I watched
it and I was like oh well that works um
but I hadn't really done any other
Christmas horror this year so usually I
try to do like a lot of holiday horror
around uh this time um and I hadn't done
books or movies or anything like that so
so obviously I thought it was about time
to rectify that uh
situation now uh so in my Kindle
unlimited
recommendations I kept noticing what was
very obviously like a Christmas themed
horror novel popping up um because it
kind of has like a what looks like kind
of a monster Christmas tree on the
cover also mysteriously has the supposed
author's name crossed out and replaced
with another name which actually doesn't
make any sense if you're just looking at
it but it's actually a pretty clever
detail that makes a lot more sense like
after you've read the book you know what
I mean so this book is everything is
temporary by John con now this was
published early November
2023 and I have to say uh this book was
a hell of a lot of fun I had a really
good time with this one um it's really
kind of like the perfect
entertaining and also kind of scary but
mostly just kind of fun um just
Christmas read it's just perfect for
this time of year I'm going to say that
if you're a fan of movies like maybe
Krampus um The Witches from 1990 uh Home
Alone A Christmas Story stuff like that
and also if you're a fan of Stephen
King's it either in book or movie form
then you will probably I mean this will
probably be right up your alley because
the novel this novel is kind of a mashup
of all those things but it also has like
its own unique kind of vibe going on you
know what I mean um it's also pretty
cool cuz it's a really well executed
story within a story or like a book
within a book um which is a Trope that I
always like uh you know provided that's
done well which which it is here I
really liked that a
lot so at the beginning of the book
there's a bit of a prologue type
situation involving a terminally ill uh
13 or 14 I believe she is uh year old
girl named
Maya now she has leukemia but she's been
through chemotherapy and she seems to be
improving like it seems like so much so
that uh her best friend Emma has
actually been able to come over and
spend the day with her like you know
what I mean for the first time in ages
and ages because she's been too sick and
so the girls have just this fantastic
time like going out in the town and like
you know celebrating Christmas
essentially and you know just playing
and eating cookies and all that kind of
fun
stuff however later on that night after
Maya goes to bed she thinks she sees
something it kind of skittering around
in the shadows of her
bedroom and sure enough uh this whatever
it is climbs on top of her with just
these kind of like red and green
twinkling eyes and then the book kind of
like cuts to Black
right um as much as a book can cut to
black but you know what I mean use your
imagination if it was a movie now the
next day uh Maya's parents are obviously
grief stricken to discover that their
daughter Maya has passed away in the
night now they're obviously I mean she
had leukemia so they're not entirely
surprised they were kind of braced for
this eventuality I guess um cuz even
though Maya can't cancer had seemed to
be getting better they didn't really
have any Illusions about the gravity
like how ill she was you know what I
mean um of course her parents don't have
any clue at all about this mysterious
something or other that you're led to
believe really killed her you know what
I
mean so from this point on we actually
kind of pivot and follow the family of
Emma who is Maya's best friend that
she'd spent her last day with now Emma
naturally just absolutely cannot believe
that best friend is gone I mean can you
imagine being like a 13 14year old girl
and having this best friend that you've
known since childhood and she's dead you
know what I mean even though she was
kind of prepared for that but still um
and but I mean she had convinced herself
that Maya was going to get better and
then you know so she was like every all
of you lied to me you said she was
getting better and so there was that
kind of going on too um now her parents
are Sarah who is uh she owns like a
startup marketing
firm um and her husband Tom who's like a
professional artist like painter type
situation he has a studio like Outback
um they kind of try their best to deal
with you know their daughter's grief
obviously um but they're also kind of
trying to work through their own
emotions at losing Maya because you know
her and her and their daughter had been
friends for so long that she was almost
like a second daughter to them so
obviously they're grieving as well
because you know she was like their own
kid so six months go by and Emma's
Behavior starts to
change now previously like over the
summer I guess this was the summer
between her being like from elementary
school or middle school or something
like that or she's going to a different
school anyway um over the summer she'd
been like you know grieving obviously
but kind of clinging to her parents and
being really nice and stuff like that
but once middle school starts uh she
gets kind of uh hostile like real
secretive [__] like that which she
wasn't anything like that before now she
is supposedly spending most of her time
with a school friend named Janice who
she will actually never let her parents
meet she always kind of like Dodges you
know the question like she never invites
her over or anything like that now Tom
and Sarah are pretty concerned about
this as you would be but they kind of
figure out oh well you know it's just
the combination of starting a new school
and being without her best friend for
the first time since childhood um you
know it's just taking a toll on her
she's that age you know what I mean and
you know they suspect that she'll get
back to normal
eventually one day though Sarah and Tom
get a call from security at the local
mall and security guard says you guys
need to come down here and pick Emma up
because she was caught destroying Mall
property so Tom and Sarah like Jesus
Christ like we need any more trouble you
know what I mean so they go down to the
mall and they find out that Emma's stunt
what she did like it wasn't
entirely intentional but it's still
something it's still damage and it's
still something that needs to be paid
for what happened was Emma claims that
she was at the mall with her friend
Janice this mysterious friend but the
Janice went into the Target store to get
something and Emma's like I didn't
really want to go in there so I got
bored and started kind of fooling around
on this one of those coin operated Kitty
rides you know the ones lit like cars
and [__] like that um but this one looks
like Santa's sleigh and she was kind of
farting around on it and she
accidentally broke it like I think she
broke off like the reindeer antlers or
something like that so the security
guard like shows Tom and sah like the
security footage and it's pretty clear
that it was all just a silly accident I
mean obviously she's too big to be
playing on it and she was just farting
around and it broke you know what I mean
she didn't really mean to do
anything but then while they're watching
the footage Tom the Dad starts acting
very strangely when he sees a man like
in a red sweatshirt in the footage who
he kind of seems to
recognize now this is evidently the same
man that he saw like passing him in his
wife earlier like on the escalator when
they first got to the mall like and he
kind of freaked out when he saw him them
but he's just like oh never mind I don't
think I saw anything blah blah now Sarah
is like kind of confused by this whole
situation she's like this dude he just
looked like a little old man like with a
red he didn't look threatening he wasn't
doing anything like Sinister or
suspicious or anything like he wasn't
even looking at them or anything um so
like why the hell is Tom reacting with
this kind of with horror you know what I
mean it's just he's just freaking out
you know what I mean now Tom says oh
it's just because you know this guy gave
me really bad vibes like don't you ever
get that from somebody or something like
that but Sarah is kind of start like the
way that he reacts she's kind of
starting to wonder if maybe you know Tom
who had previously been pretty
reasonable and chill um might be
starting to kind of like lose it a
little bit you know what I mean cuz he's
acting really
weird so these suspicions uh would seem
to be confirmed like after they get home
and Tom makes a way way way bigger deal
about the mall incident than it really
kind of warrants you know what I mean it
was just a silly accident yeah they had
to pay for it but it's not like she
meant to do it you know what I mean but
he starts like interrogating Emma on why
she specifically chose
the kitty ride that looked like Santa
sleigh to play on and basically he
starts straight up accusing her of lying
about being at the mall with Janice and
instead being there with this mysterious
dude like in the red sweatshirt who
didn't even who wasn't even like
interacting with or looking at Emma like
in the footage you know what I mean so
it's just like it sounds like crazy talk
what he saying now Sarah who again
thinks it sounds like crazy talk which
it does does she's just trying to figure
out what the hell is going on with her
husband right and she's like well it you
know the Santa slay thing why are you
fixating on that is this something to do
with your mom dying on Christmas like a
long time ago when you were a kid and
he's just like yeah maybe but um I also
just have like a really bad feeling
about something like I feel like
something terrible is going to happen
and he's sure that Emma is keeping
information from them and he is like
bound and determined to like figure out
it is right and he basically goes and
like searches her room and then goes
completely [__] ballistic when he
finds like an elf hat in his daughter's
backpack and he's like where did you get
this and all this other kind of stuff
and Emma's like dude chill out like I
just got it from school you know what I
mean they were doing a play or some [__]
like that and I don't really understand
what your problem is like why are you
flipping out so much and like I said his
wife's starting to feel like what the
[__] is wrong with this dude he's acting
like completely crazy so so yeah so like
I said Sarah's kind of struggling with
it this cuz she's like oh my God my
husband's a lunatic um you know maybe
he's developing schizophrenia or
something like she doesn't know you know
what I mean um and he won't really give
her any
answers however then she does find out
that Emma was actually lying about
having a friend named Janice this Janice
girl it turns out she doesn't know her
at all she just like chose this name at
random like from school and like told
them you know so they're like well where
the hell have you been every day then if
you said you were hanging out with
Janice but this girl doesn't even know
you so it does turn out that Emma is
lying about some
stuff so Sarah the mom she's just man
trying to like keep everything together
like I said everything's just like the
[__] hitting the fan like over and over
again um you know she's got her
fledgling business that she's starting
out doing and there's problems there
she's trying to keep that [__] together
because she's kind of the main
Breadwinner like Tom makes money too
like he's a professional artist but it's
kind of clear that she makes more money
but it's a startup so she's kind of
spending a lot of money too cuz she's
trying trying to get it off the ground
so she's kind of trying to keep all the
[__] together at home and at work and
everything like that and then like the
next day or two days later or something
like that she gets another blow in the
form of a phone call from the police
telling her that her husband has been
arrested for attempted murder and she's
like what the actual [__] did you just
say you know what I mean she's like my
mild mannered husband attempted Mur okay
it turns out that he tried to burn down
like a local house with the person still
inside it like on
purpose um now Sarah is absolutely
mystified as to why Tom would do this
because she's like she's never even
heard of the guy that her husband was
allegedly trying to kill you know what I
mean now by way of
explanation Tom calls his wife from jail
and says I need you to look for this old
box that's in my art studio um and it
says like Tom's junk on it and he said
in there is a book that I wrote a long
time ago called Everything Is
temporary and he says this book you read
it it's going to explain everything
that's going on and he also kind of
gives a copy of it to his lawyer because
hopefully it's going to exonerate him
for the attempted murder charges somehow
he doesn't really explain how that's
going to
happen so once Sarah goes home and finds
the book the novel switches back and
forth between Sarah's point of view like
first person and excerpts from Tom's
book which is called Everything Is
temporary just like the actual book you
know what I mean so Tom's
book
details uh this
unbelievable like increasingly
unbelievable series of incidents that
supposedly happened to Tom when he was a
kid um now he slightly changed the name
names of all the people involved but
he's still obvious like who he's talking
about you know what I mean so yeah so
it's kind of like going back and forth
from like his childhood to the present
day like it's mirroring you know what I
mean now I'm not going to this is a new
book so I'm not going to spoil what all
those events are but I will say that
they involve a Christmas house like for
terminally ill children which is the
thing that really exists where you know
terminally old children can go and
celebrate Christmas in case they're not
really going to make it to actual
Christmas which is depressing but um you
know it is something that exists like a
service that exists so that factors in
there's also this grandmotherly cookie
scented wonderful woman named Mrs Claus
who may not be what she seems we'll put
it that way and also kind of an array of
Christmas ornaments and humble figurines
and stuff like that that apparently can
come to life with Christmas magic which
is kind of the part that reminded me of
Krampus now Tom the dad he insists that
everything in this book really happened
to him when he was a kid like it's all
true and so Sarah like as she's reading
it and it's getting like more like
crazier and crazier she's like basically
has to deal with the fact that her
husband might not only like be losing
his ever loving mind clearly but that if
he gets in trouble like if he gets
convicted he's going to maybe have to
spend conceivably like 5 to 20 years in
prison you know what I mean and she's
not really sure much how like which is
worse and the thing about it too and I
like that they kind of that JN con kind
of also brought up the financial
ramifications because like for her for
Sarah to get her husband out on bail
like she had to basically close down her
company so she didn't have those
expenses anymore and you know had to try
and get a job somewhere else to bring in
money like to pay for his bail and the
lawyer and everything like that so I
like that they kind of
talked a lot about that too like about
the you know the extra stress that was
like on her because they were running
out of money you know what I mean now so
as I mentioned for Christmas hor this
was an absolute blast like from the
beginning to end just super fun um super
suspenseful like and it was just kind of
like this unspooling
mystery and I liked all the characters
you actually really cared about them and
it has just this real wild very
Christmas heavy plot that just gets more
and more outlandish like as it goes on
but in a good way you know what I mean
um and I'm going to say too I really
liked that having the bulk of the story
like switching back and forth from Tom's
book like about his childhood to Sarah's
first person point of view so you could
get inside her head I think that was
good because that I mean that was a good
decision because I think that really
grounded it because you could really
feel her
disbelief um at this you know
increasingly bizarre story that her
husband was telling her and you could
really kind of like empathize with her
predicament and it's like you know she's
obviously doesn't think any of this is
real she's like how can it be it seems
like impossible because the story is
like he's telling this crazy but she's
like oh my God like you know not only am
I running out of money my daughter's
freaking out like an acting crazy you
know Tom's acting crazy he might go to
prison and all this other kind of [__]
um you know it's just like my husband's
sitting here talking about like [__]
monster Christmas trees and you know
nefarious Hummel figurines that come to
life and [__] like that and he's like
going completely insane and like what
the [__] like everything is just like
falling apart like at one time so you
really got a good sense of of that like
from her point of view cuz you were like
inside of her head a lot of the time and
I will say too that the climax of this I
thought was really really well done
really satisfying um had kind of like a
great final battle in which I feel like
the characters like felt like they were
in real danger you know what I mean like
the the author is not afraid to like
kill some people off you know what I
mean so I'm going to say that um so I
mentioned Stephen King's It Before um I
think fans of that will probably really
dig this because it has kind of a
similar plot structure of like a group
of kids having to fight a monster and
then having to fight the same Monster
again like as adults it's not really
like it a lot but it does have that
aspect to it so it's similar in that
regard um but yeah this definitely has
its own thing going on and it leans
really really hard into the Christmas
angle which I thought was like really
delightful like it is definitely like a
Christmas monster story you know what I
mean um but yeah I thought this was like
really really fun like I said and I
would you know recommend it unreservedly
and if you have Kindle unlimited like I
do then you can read it for free or you
know if you want to help the author out
you can buy a paperback or whatever but
I think this is like a really cool
Christmas horror like a monster horror
to read around Christmas time and I
really really liked it a lot so you know
maybe you will too check it out if
you've read it I think maybe I thought I
saw that Tammy was reading it so if
you've read it Tammy tell me what you
think about it and if any of you other
guys have read it then tell me what you
think about it too cuz I really really
liked it a lot but yeah so I'm going to
uh wrap it up for the day hopefully you
guys enjoyed this little Christmas book
review that I did here I'll probably do
another Christmas horror movie probably
be Christmas Bloody Christmas
um I will either do it Thursday or I
might save it till Sunday I don't really
know I if I have time to watch another
Christmas horror movie then I'll do one
Thursday and Sunday but we'll see how it
goes so yeah uh thanks everybody for
listening and I'll see you guys again on
the next one
bye